when you think of Sweden what comes to
mind
IKEA ABBA maybe those delicious cinnamon
rolls but what about these Swedish
meatballs right well maybe not
welcome to the meatball mystery let's
cut straight to the chase it's hard to
make the Swedes angry but on one fateful
day something happened that fired up the
whole country this tweet was sent from
the official Sweden Twitter account
Swedish meatballs actually based on a
recipe from King Charles at all brought
back from Turkey in the early 18th
century let stick to the facts did you
catch that the tweet said that Swedish
meatballs actually come from Turkey as
you can imagine the tweet went viral
Swedes were up in arms it was picked up
all around the world the Swedish
government has admitted Swedish
meatballs are actually Turkish what what
no that's not affect the facts is really
interesting since we don't have any
effects from that period
why do you my name is Richard Carlson
and I'm a food historian okay here's
what we know in the 1700s Swedish King
Charles the 12th lost a battle in the
great northern war he was forced to flee
to the Ottoman Empire where for several
years he negotiated his return the
controversial tweet suggested that he
brought back a local Turkish meat dish
called koftas however there is no
documented interest from him in food no
mentioning of the meatballs sir they are
not Turkish because we can't follow the
original meatballs in the world there is
no zero meatball where everything
started most likely origin of the
meatball is development in parallel ways
in parallel food cultures therefore
meatballs are very different all of the
world but they exist all over the world
today it's one of Sweden's most popular
dishes traditionally served with mashed
potatoes a brown gravy and a sweet
lingonberry sauce
[Music]
food gives us an example of how we are
connected when it comes to capture food
is a sort of cultural network so take
pride in your meatballs Sweden and so
should Turkey China Italy in every
meatball rollin country because if
there's one thing the world can agree on
is that meatballs are delicious